"Дівчата зі Львова" - серіал про українських заробітчанок у Польщі.
Його популярність і в Польщі, і в Україні чудово ілюструє те,
наскільки сильно тема трудової міграції зачіпає як українців, так і поляків.
Тим часом генпрокурор України Юрій Луценко 1 листопада заспокоїв львівських студентів,
мовляв, міграція українців у Європу не перевищує кількості поляків, які виїхали на заробітки з Польщі.
Різниця між тими, хто виїхав, і хто в'їхав, минулого року була 200 тисяч, котрі там лишилися.
Цього року 600 з хвостиком.
При цьому офіційно з Польщі виїхало 6 мільйонів.
DW перевірила, чи справді
За дослідженнями трудової міграції Державної служби статистики України,
в період з 2015 по 2017 рік на заробітки за кордон виїхали понад 1 мільйон 300 тисяч українців.
Із них повернулися понад 560 тисяч.
Міграційне сальдо складає 740 тисяч осіб.
Якщо рівномірно розподілити на три роки - то Україну щороку залишали близько 250 тисяч осіб.
Трудову міграцію спричиняють низькі зарплати та безробіття в країні.
За даними Мінфіну, рівень безробіття у 2017 році сягнув майже 10%,
це найгірший показник за останні 14 років.
Одним із найбільш улюблених маршрутів українських заробітчан є Польща.
Вона у 2017 році стала країною-лідером в ЄС,
яка видала найбільше дозволів на проживання іноземцям - 700 тисяч за даними Євростату.
Із них 85% - українцям.
Створюючи сприятливі умови для українських трудових мігрантів,
Польща компенсує власну нестачу робочих рук.
Адже після приєднання до Євросоюзу у 2004 році,
у Польщі гостро постала проблема відтоку робочої сили у багатші країни ЄС.
Попри те, що рівень безробіття в Польщі - один з найнижчих в ЄС - лише 3,4%.
Не зрозуміло, звідки і за який період Луценко взяв цифру,
що з Польщі офіційно виїхало шість мільйонів поляків.
У 2016 році з Польщі на довгостроковій основі виїхали майже 240 тисяч осіб.
Такі дані наводить Statista.
При цьому в'їхали в Польщу близько 208 тисяч людей, зокрема й українців.
Тож міграційне сальдо у 2016 році складає усього лише 28 тисяч осіб.
Тоді як в Україні лише середнє міграційне сальдо за 2015-2017 роки - майже 250 тисяч людей.
А якщо вірити даним генпрокурора, то у 2018 році - у два з половиною рази гірше - 600 тисяч.
Теза про те, що на заробітки з України в Європу виїжджає не більше людей, ніж з Польщі -
не відповідає дійсності, особливо якщо брати однаковий часовий проміжок.
Поляків виїжджає близько 250 тисяч, а міграційне сальдо складає лише кілька десятків тисяч осіб.
Тоді як в Україні лише міграційне сальдо обчислюється сотнями тисяч українців.